пан планової сирого горища зараз
знайшли годину для дачі були зарізані ми
даному тіньовому секторі України про
буває вигляд 30 до 50 і обличчя такі
фінансових ресурсів що на вашу підлогу і від
можна було б за протон біля води бізнесу б
ви сході кошт істині
то поспішає і над хід дружині бюджет по дотці
ось від України на до острова створи ти
таки розумом ще опція була задля добра
будуть його fete не заощаджувати та щуп стимул
завищувати в тіні бум менший
раба звук романів че ти так проти ти
державних агентів у державу щоб бізнес
і їх на кубу і зовсім топ тут
децентралізація дерегуляція сьогодні з
головна реформа за брязкіт вручення сектору
тіньової економіки скорочення від мене я
твій економіки йогор have кулінар і в
україні багаті всі ванної монополісти ви
за крим любить ще олігархи трава за
брата ці правила і я кате труби ти треба
зробити це вже робиться список треба
зарубає і пар олег монополії
який державний які private не з
лайте демонополізація акція
кинула скажемо в Польщі 25 рогатому це
було у нас іншою чуму економіка польші
повчала розвиватися і було раніше і
над м'яз vip його тебе в економіці
українці в більшості і раніше ніж
економіка України
останній розмістити роботи в Україні ви
заявила Україну відсікає зростання не
економіка вечора чи меценат військовий де
у донбасі та завис області економічних
дитячий з криму з краву
просто вже почав зрощення вже почалося
і вид початку в вона була правильним його
на закріпіть усі лідери україни йде
то реалізує пакет реформ це дуже
складно біля vic-20 агресія росії
проти України найкраще відповісти
українці було б розвиватися, що зійшли за
допомогу та реформ там вчитель до
економіка ще розвивається може давати
віконках же
ви ння ви дотки військових з військових
витрат дику душі за овоч чи поведінку
дуже дякую